[Musik]
derzeit nicht so gut vorbereitet werden
tut mir leid du bist immer noch gut
ich meine nur das ist alles in ordnung
ja ja ich habe noch viel stress ein
praktikum ist ziemlich anstrengend aber
es macht auch großen spaß
architektur ist super interessant und
mein chef ist sehr zufrieden mit mir ja
alles andere würde mich auch wundern
wenn ihm gerade an einer
projektausschreibung teil des total
spannend worum geht es denn es geht um
den entwurf für eine neue brücke und
nicht auf auch einen vorschlag machen
und der gewinner entwurf wird vielleicht
wirklich gebaut stell dir das mal vor
eine wichtige brücke wo es immer das ist
das klingt großartig aber es ist
eigentlich ein wettbewerb für junge
architekten die können wissen natürlich
viel mehr als ich es ist also sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass ich gewinnen aber
es ist ein anfang
[Musik]
bis dann
ich bin schon sehr gespannt auf seine
brücke